this border is here to keep foreigners
out Border Patrol's detained almost half
a million people last year alone here at
the southern edge of the United States
on weekends US border guards open up
what's called friendship park here
family and friends on both sides of the
border are reunited well sort of so
Mexicans living in the US illegally can
see their loved ones i'm here to see
daniel who wants to come to the US but
can't so I'm actually not allowed to
talk to Daniel across the border for
security reasons for me crossing the
fence is no problem it's a quick drive
from California down to Tijuana in
northern Mexico that's where Daniels
been living for the past four years his
parents brother and sister are four of
the twelve million people who live in
the u.s. undocumented he lived there too
for 10 years before he had to go and
just looking at that border I mean it
doesn't make you feel angry angry know
kind of s'mores like sad you know like I
just want to jump up front over and go
home but I can't and you could I mean
some people do that yeah but then what
you know I would still be stuck in a
place where I couldn't go to work
school I couldn't have a life like I
wanted to so yeah you could just jump
the border and be over there and big
fruit and vegetables for eight hours an
hour I mean it's not it's not it's not
as easy or as comfortable as most people
think other moments when you seriously
consider doing it yeah course my mother
just survived cancer and at some point
she was really sick and for a moment
there I thought she wasn't gonna make it
so i was planning of crossing the desert
illegally into united states just so i
could see my mother Daniel didn't just
live in the u.s. he risked his life in
battle for the US as a marine in iraq
but when they found out he wasn't a US
citizen they kicked him out the military
we have the same of no man left behind
well they're leaving us behind you know
they're there there's they're making it
so our service it's not good enough just
because we had the bad luck of not
living men are being born in the United
States I mean we we're not just illegals
who have been deported we are and we
will always be at heart Americans who
have been banished you know who have
been left out from the one place that we
love
it's been four years since Daniel ended
up what he sees as the wrong side of the
border he's had to build a new life in
Mexico find new friends and figure out
how to make ends meet the 29 year old
lives with his grandma here in Tijuana
his old hometown hey we're here where
necessary from what their friend come
with their friend yeah okie dokie what
the room hey music what no yes putting
away the past hasn't been easy for
Daniel once a marine always a Marine of
course to enlist Daniel claimed he had
US citizenship the marine corpse turned
a blind eye you lied when when you
enlisted yeah were you aware of that
yeah i mean i knew i wasn't born in
united states uh but it was the only way
to enlist and had the opportunity to
serve the country that i was living in
you know there's always when you grow up
that's the Mexican United States so was
this a stigma of taking our jobs or
they're just feeding off the system and
I didn't want to be another Mexican the
United States I wanted to be able to say
hey you know what I did something I
served this country and I was willing to
put my life on the line for it
after he got kicked out of the Marines
Daniel face deportation he chose to
leave voluntarily instead yeah come on
now phone calls are the closest he can
get to his family there are 1.3 million
people living in Tijuana but like Daniel
many of them don't want to be here
they're waiting for the chance to make
it to the States some have already lived
there been deported and are hoping to
get back
Daniel thought he could build a future
here he started University next year
he'll finish his degree in law but over
the past four years his hopes about
living in this country have faded now he
can't imagine staying the thing is that
when i got here to Mexico I I didn't
realize how American I was until I get
Mexico you know and that's when it hit
me that I don't identify with the
culture I don't identify with the people
I don't identify with with its
government which political system with
the way thing they do things
Tijuana is a city of broken dreams every
day here people climb over the fence
lots of them get picked up and descent
right back to Mexico
last year u.s. Border Patrol stopped
almost half a million people on the
other side of the fence most of them
Mexicans and that same time the u.s.
deported almost a hundred and eighty
thousand Mexicans
deported US soldiers in Tijuana come
here to Hector Barajas himself a u.s.
veteran who's also trying to help Daniel
out Daniels cases a little is a little
unique because he was undocumented but
most of us served legally we were in the
United States legally we were drafted
into combat in the Vietnam War so these
were people that put their life on the
line for the American government why for
example your own case or like most
people why are they important the
majority of the veterans that are being
deported committed some type of crime
after they were in the military war
while in the military but the majority
after so we got out served in
Afghanistan and the gulf war with
honorable discharges after the military
because a lot of the men are suffering
from post-traumatic syndrome they come
back from the war they don't know how to
cope with it they start drinking they
might start using then in order to to
keep that habit they might rob somebody
or rob steal something and then family
go to jail they get deported after their
service most non US veterans like Hector
commit a crime and after their jail time
they are deported there are no figures
on how many non US veterans have been
deported but Hector says it's got to be
more than 3,000 so so I have some good
news for you and this is a a an email
from the UAC are you and you know this
is not a hundred percent but this is
what I have have you spoken to the
individual who you mentioned had falsely
claimed US citizenship on his
application for the military it does not
appear that did that that would bar his
naturalization and basically to put you
in contact with her song you might go
home brother perfect perfect that's what
that's not harder yeah that's what I
needed me and there's some lawyer to
look at it come on yeah and that Oh
that'll turn this nightmare you know so
perfect I don't know it's too much like
I I'm excited I just I want to I don't
want to like jinx aight i don't want to
get my hopes up i just wanted to do it
one step at a time and hopefully he
works out and I i get to get home
definitely that's what I want
American coca-cola
just looking at Daniel you'd hardly know
it's the news he's been hoping to hear
for years he's probably just too afraid
of getting us hopes up in case it
doesn't work out I didn't choose to come
to United States but it's a place that I
fell in love with and I now call my home
and all those mistakes that has made in
the past I just hope I don't have to pay
for them for the rest of my life